yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby look
guys the aristocrats are back
Aristocrats are back um well not me you
the I was on Daddy Duty tiger had a uh
before we into your fantastic weekend
yes yeah I got to hear was do that let
me hear compare your weekend to mine
baby came home I haven't seen you since
I know baby came home thank you for
giving it mouth to mouth uh baby came
home she's all good baby she's all good
she has two brothers and then tiger had
his first travel ball tournament he
baled out Bal out kid went yard kid went
yard which is rear for a seven-year-old
okay yeah um but then you got remember
used to playing with all white kids when
you do travel ball it's the best of the
best of the surrounding areas so this
team came from I don't know Elsa Gund or
whatever and then went well we don't
come from where you come from and all we
do is play baseball so we're going to
beat the [__] out of you white Devils oh
okay they had a pcture on there built
like uh Tito Ortiz that didn't miss how
old was he seven and went threw a no
hitter what threw a no hitter what at
seven yep didn't miss throwing junk at
seven Tiger's like I don't know I'm like
I don't want to tell you dude you're
white half Mexican so you should be able
to hit it and he uh he well what
happened was he got he got into the real
world and realized he's very good but
there are a lot of other people that are
very good he's right there he's right
there yeah that's why I told him I said
it's good for you to see this stuff
that's that's your comp yeah like the
bubble we're in there's kids who this is
they eat sleep and and he's like well
then that's what I want to do if you
take a month off then you you pay a
price he didn't take a month off though
yeah he's he's on it so did that man
levels right and I got new friends now
that Dad group bro we sit in the right
field it's a good time dude it's you
know what it is it's life D it's life
when they lost the first game on Sunday
I looked at the dad like damn now we got
to go home man cuz they would have won
we' have kept going we would have won
the tournament and it was just fun to
hang with them oh dude we got Bears cuz
they've been doing it they have older
kids too so they've been through the
system so I pull a seat up they got lawn
chairs the one had a grill out the back
they is there anything better is there
just watching your kids play ball it's
it's funny how you get to an age when
you have kids and that right there is
what you'd rather be doing over anything
else dude I've done a lot of cool [__]
in my life that's right nothing better
than that thank you thank you I was
there from me and T got there earlier to
warm up his game was at 99 so I was
there from 7:30 to 4: I was watching on
my I was good there was a guy who was
pitching his first Major League Baseball
game pitched a got him out of the inning
you're watching a rerun yes yeah okay
and his father is there and his his
first time his father's in the stands
first time he's seen his son on the
mound in the pros in the pros in a major
league game yeah different animal and uh
threw and struck struck all three
batters out and his father's doing this
try not to cry oh oh dude it was tattoo
on my face yeah it'd be sick I get it
it's the best I get it but how was your
weekend well uh first of all I apologize
if I look a little robust and I if I
look if I my energy is a little on point
it might be a little much I smarter I
look smarter but I also ate I lived on
nothing but uh uh venison Partridge and
pheasant the animals I slew the animals
I slew I went went hunting as you know
oh you and you you you were eating what
you killed I ate what I killed okay are
you lying a little bit right some of
those meals some of those meals right
okay now here's the thing that didn't
happen now hold on do I think you guys
went hunting sure now did you only kill
I ate a lot of venison the thing is the
venison that I shot the deer ey shot you
got to hang for a week can't just eat
him oh you can't do that yeah you got
you got you got robu you gotow fallow
deer and you've got um monk Jack look up
monk Jack for a second but why do you
have to hang him because the meat is
especially with monk Jack delicious meat
it's so hard believe it or not the the
muscle is so hard do a shred bill
because all they do is run that if you
that's that's a full grown monk Jack hey
man I know the thing's cute as [__] I
know it is it's looks dude don't kill
monk Jacks so I so I'm I'm getting to
that I bet Tim Kennedy bit his nose off
well Tim Tim that's the cutest deer I've
ever seen my that's a full grown baby
deer that's a full grown monk Jack now
hold on for those you only listen to
this and think of the cutest baby dare
you've ever seen But full grown the
biggest prettiest size you've ever seen
the juiciest nose soft as a feather
Brian in the face no I saw it I saw monk
Jack three types of deer Robuck Ro deer
phow deer monk Jack I saw a monk Jack it
was so small I thought it was a pheasant
and I I did not slay it I pulled my gun
up I could kill that thing with a with a
with a blow dart I could kill that thing
with a paintball you throw stone and
you thing with a butter knife and you
guys have AK-47s oh no we have we have H
we do have hunting rifles yeah now
that's a that's a delicious is that even
hunting it's a delicious piece of meat
but I I saw it and I I I drew a bead and
then I went you know I'm not going to
I'm not going to kill that deer now
that's half a lie too that's a lie CU it
ran into the bush but I don't think I
would have pulled the trigger I just
didn't it was too cute too little shot
the [__] out of AOW deer though no a a
roo actually you know I don't like right
now what you know what's triggering me
you keep naming off these random dare
like like were Hunters too and like you
know too also like I know yeah you know
what it's like me being at a car shop
and like is that that's the cam shaft
there you guys going to switch that out
okay so now you're going to love this so
you know the people that I went hunting
I'll shoot that people I went hunting
with uh you know our our dear friend Tim
Kennedy I got spend a wonderful five
days myor one of my favorite people on
Earth and everything I thought about Tim
is compounded the smartest coolest just
most and then we went into the water in
the Atlantic now I don't know if you
know it's winter time right it's winter
time when in the Atlantic atantic so so
Bri got got Bri had to go cuz Tim I was
trying to sleep pretending to be asleep
cuz I didn't want to go in the water I
was cold and Tim literally goes Brian
and and he could tell by my breathing
because he's trained he's trained he's
[__] trained and I was I was doing
the fake I was doing the fake thing I
was like you know how you breathe you're
like I was doing that and he knew that I
was lying yeah and I just feel this
[__] body on me and he just gets on
me he goes you're coming you're coming
swimming you're not you're not sleeping
I can tell by your is it all of you or
just you and Tim oh no it's me it's Tim
Kennedy it's a guy named Jimmy Johnson
you guys know who Jimmy Johnson is how
know who Jim you guys don't wait the
football dude or no he's the he's the
Jimmy John greatest NASCAR drivers of
all time handsome bastard too Brian goes
look who I'm with I'm like do you
realize who you're with right now not
that Jimmy Johnson but no that's I just
typed in Jimmy Johnson but underneath
you see the NASCAR yeah I'm going get to
him in a sec I'm going to get to Jimmy
Johnson in a sec who's who's my new
didn't know who he was look at out look
at oh of course yeah I know Legend did
you know he's from California uh from
Cali he is he's from San Diego there he
is just always always looks like that go
to his records though chin you're
talking like you were driving with the
Walter pton dude which I didn't not
blind which I knew nothing about all I
knew is I look at this guy who's about
six feet and handsome as all get out and
uh I meet him I meet him with Tim
they're at a pub I meet well as soon as
I get off the plane I drive to the pub I
meet Tim and Jimmy Johnson but I why it
was embarrassing because Brian's on like
FaceTime with him he goes he goes he
goes Jimmy look my friend Bren here he's
a car guy I was
like no no no no no no no no no no no
not no no no yeah no I like cars well I
got color on that which you'll like
about him but but to finish my my Tim
Kennedy story he gets on me now he drags
me to the ocean I put on a wet suit cuz
it's the winter in the Atlantic it's the
have a wet suit on we didn't have a wet
suit that fit Tim cuz I don't know if
you know this very thick leg Yeah his
back he's thick big wiener so um yes by
the way that too that big American
wiener yeah he's got a big American a
big American wiener and so uh he went in
shorts um and I went but it's the it's
the Atlantic and the winter and I was in
a wet suit and I had to get out after 15
minutes cuz I couldn't stop shaking
because my hands and my feet my forearms
and my face not for you not for me B you
weren't built for that life no no no I
wasn't no I would never make it in the
Navy Seals because well I would get
hypothermia immediately Tim on me I went
hey Brian listen I'm going to go for a
dip warm up the Coco you stay here in
the cabin warm up the Coco you do well
in the cold like that right you're fine
yeah good I don't have that I don't I
don't have your Constitution or Tims I
get it and Tim was in the water four one
hour just swimming in the yeah in the
Atlantic just to stay in just swimming
just he was actually not swimming he was
surfing in in very strong current the
current was taking people to the rocks
and my buddy Joey goes I've been out
here with 100 people uh he's the only
guy I've ever seen who is completely
relaxed he lives for the ocean he's aqu
danger yeah he likes danger so then uh
Jimmy was out there with the with the
surfboard I was Boogie boarding sir I
was Boogie boarding and I and I rode I
was Afra did you feel gay oh I am gay
when your boys are like out in the seres
gay and they're like does anyone have a
boogie board well I'm a piece of [__]
yeah I came back that should do it well
well I came back realizing that I'm
nothing oh then this was a success this
was a success no no I realized I'm I'm
nothing nothing CU I don't I fly
commercially I don't know if and
sometimes a lot of times coach so yeah
I'm with you meanwhile Tim K's fighting
for your freedom missions we don't know
about and then Jimmy Johnson's I don't
know worth half a billion dollars one of
the greatest nicec car drivers of all
time you would never know he's worth
anything he's the most you no idea like
he's the most he's so humble it's
ridiculous we're all hanging out eating
dinner and the guy's getting up and
cutting us pie asking if you want more
drinks making drinks for people I'm like
this [__] Tim Kennedy said about we
all everybody had a crush on him we all
had crush on but Tim's not an ascar guy
either did he know is I'm sorry did Tim
know the magnitude didn't know until Tim
put it together and then look then
started reading I have a video of of of
him reading Jimmy's accomplishments off
AI tell you bud and it was like I was
like staggering oh I'm dealing with
Michael Jordan you could have got me an
engine bro so so so he's invited me and
and yourself oh you no you're just on
the on the on the on the third wheel but
I'll text him I'm the fat chick at the
party let me bring no they invite the
hot girls BR friend I'll bring my chubby
the fat friend who's into the music that
they're playing you're my chubby plus
one oh man and I and I I we'll go to
Daytona I've been invited to a couple of
these things right so we'll go there now
now he uh Jimmy I need an engine yeah
see what he drives right now I forget
what he's what he's what company's with
but it was my my buddy of course Joey
Joey janor our our dear friend who owns
all that stuff and was own he was our
host he owns England the island he owns
he owns everything England and he was
awesome he's a great Surfer and
Toyota no no no he's daily driver I
that's not his daily goddamn driver T
what are you trying to do how about
about what the hell you trying to do I
don't know man BBA how about this I go I
ask him I go like this I go you do you
have do you have cars you have a lot of
cars and he goes Noah not really I go
what like how many cars do you have and
he goes I mean you know not a lot I go
five he goes well and I go 10 he he goes
I mean I go how much and he go I mean
about 25 I go that's a lot of cars did
you ask him what kind yeah I saw there's
a there's a there's a there's a video
any car you know in there he likes
American muscle
cars take it easy I know he take Tim
Kennedy after we hung out with him for
two days because we were like we all had
a man crush on him and Tim mckenny
looked at Joe and goes Hey Joe is there
a button on him like is there a button
we can push where it turns out he's just
a cyborg he's not even real cuz he's
like he's he looks that good and he also
dresses like he he showed up in like the
best English hunting clothes he looks
like a [__]
model yeah by the way he doesn't know a
lot about cars though in terms of like
the engines cuz my friend was like is
that a six liter oh he's like me he goes
is that is that a six liter he goes I
don't know he goes no what kind of shaft
are you driving he goes I I I don't know
you know what's inter about that is
those Car Guys when they're that maybe
that's different with I know my he's the
athlete he's the athlete who drives it
yeah but it's also like uh uh Daniel
Ricardo who's a massive F1 driver they
sh when you talk about cars like yeah
yeah yeah like I'm like hey does that
have the 450 you know or is that a V10
or they're like I don't know man you
know they're like what they don't know
no or they're just like it's like when
like a a person I know fighting talks to
me like ah God damn it so I'm sure
that's how we are with with cars like
what he do and they do it for a living
it's like yeah it's a Viper I don't know
right but but I didn't know that in
NASCAR was four or five hours I didn't
know that you are you're it doesn't know
power steering Tona 500 500 laps it's
crazy so you're it's such a phys
sport too Tim was taking Tim was taking
me Joey me and Joey are 57 56 and then
and then uh Jimmy's 48 and Tim of course
is 45 but Superman and Tim would take us
through these CrossFit things like body
weight nightmare right nightmare I bet
Jimmy did well at it Jimmy was had he
had no problem because he's an endurance
yeah some of those guys are freaks man
freaks it's a whole thing and then
mentally obviously Tim Kenny number one
but mental I mean Jimmy John comptitive
competitor at his level yeah yeah
outlier dude be let's take a little
break dude cuz it's chilly out in La man
but it's getting a lot more chil in
Chicago until you get there oh dude
you're bringing heat yeah it's still
freezing whether I bring heat or not I'm
just saying you're your comedy like it I
like it December 8th you be there I
don't have that much heat okay December
not enough for chile Chicago I'm there
this Friday and Saturday only two shows
Friday two shows Saturday take a thick
boy.com where you going to be B you know
buddy I'm glad you asked War hope this
weekend it's not warm it's Indianapolis
Indiana and I'll be there December 7 8
and 9 but if you guys feel the
temperature change on Thursday when I
land it's cuz global warming and because
I'm bringing heat myself that thato span
Comedy Club after that dude and you know
what you should do is you should take
all the money you earn from your road
dates and invest in gold coins dude it's
the it's the new hotness be like Scrooge
McDuck don't try and jump in all the
coins to break your neck those those are
cartoons look with everything going on
in the world war inflation the economy
right now could be the best time ever to
diversify your money and savings with
precious metals like gold silver tell
about it Bri has gold ever lost his
value anybody ever hand you a bar of
gold throughout all of history and and
anybody been like n I'm okay said no one
never gold bars gold teeth literally
gold has been it's the primary element
so it just never you can have gold and
it looks the same after 10,000 years
they're rated A Plus by the Better
Business Bureau they've earned over 5
festar reviews okay that's just
mentioning a few of gold CO's
accomplishments okay and right now for
fighter and kid listeners they're
offering up to $110,000 in bonus silver
while supplies last so go to Gold co.com
fighter learn more that's gold co.com
quick quick just while we're doing this
quick trivia question for you guys does
gold ever rust what happens to Gold if
it sits in a room for 2,000 years what
comes bronze dumb asses nothing happens
it looks exactly the same yeah it looks
exactly the same I don't even think he
collects dust no so there you go so
there's there's the holidays are here
everybody has like you know certain
go-to items of clothing you reach near
thing you know you got that t-shirt I
have that in underwear and my meundies
underwear I've been wearing and and I've
been wearing probably literally 10 years
some I know it sounds crazy got right
now break down I've had the same pair on
for seven days well they don't break
down yeah you need to change your on
these but I smell like hummus but they
feel great you you take showers in your
meundies but really meundies is made of
micro modal it's it never loses its U I
don't know what it is elasticity and
it's so soft and it's so rugged and it's
they're the perfect underwear all kinds
of different underwe man they're
loungewear I got sweats for them I wear
them every I get home I put my cozies on
oh my God those are so good the comfy
joggers Jamies dud it's breathable it's
so nice listen for the gift that keeps
on giving knock out your holiday
shopping today get 20% off your first
order plus free shipping at meundies.com
tfatk that's meundies.com
tfatk for 20% off plus free shipping
meundies comfort from the outside in
it's a great gift for the holidays
including for your lady by the way
including for your lady or your man's or
your mans or your man's give it up give
your side piece to andies what
what say Kobe BR Mamba I talked to him
about that too he goes he feels the car
he's always been able to feel the car
with his body yep not just his arms he
feels it with his body yeah hell yeah
and he's also been doing it since he he
still has the motorbike when he was four
years old yeah they start young yes
super young [__] super I wish he were
there cuz I know you would have been oh
man you know every I would have got his
nerves huh or I would have gotten his
nerves like let me just run this by you
man I know we're whatever you're he was
I know you're hunting but listen I got
this lightning I think it's a fuel pump
problem okay fight switch that out and
get some injectors and anything I'll be
okay he's like I don't [__] know dude
he loves it though he loves it he would
you know he's just such a good guy good
H I had such a good time with those guys
I you know what I did you know what I
did most of the time I listened you know
I'm talkative you know that's my stage
if I got an audience you're not getting
out of there without you'll tell Jimmy
Johnson how to drive a 100% a thousand
things and I spent my you tell said to
me he goes dude you you were quiet and I
go I was having such a wonderful time
learning and listening T Tim I don't
know if you guys know that Tim Kennedy
graduated high school at 15 and college
at 19 which I didn't know he's brilliant
freak oh yeah interested in everything
and you know no K Tim's one of the I
mean and he and I wrestled Tim and I Tim
and I wrestled on the beach yeah we went
uh Wast of time huh no no we went
takedowns uh I I uh we we tied up a
little bit and then tussled did Jimmy
get in on that no no he just watched Tim
Tim him snaap my head down because I
wasn't you know whatever and then uh Hey
so was just like Five Guys well we also
had uh we also had some other for the
Partridge hunt we had some some some
BigTime in Big Time captains of industry
I'm gonna I won't say the names but
captains of industry yeah but then it's
just but the most times five
guys like hanging out and eating feasant
like wrestling and stuff Five Guys well
Five Guys broke off and went down to the
south of
France and that's where we went surfing
that's where Brian went body
surfing uh South France nice and cliff
diving cliff jumping Brian didn't do the
cliff jumping Brian slept oh okay ran
slept through that oh he missed out but
Tim Tim decided to go jump uh off the
highest rocks into the water sure cuz
you know yeah I wouldn't have done that
either no the thing is when you're all
together you end up doing it you know
get pure pressure yeah unless you are
unless you sleep did Jimmy do
it Jimmy didn't jump off the too much
money he he was down for anything he was
down he was but also he's like yeah come
on yeah yeah I got to Dodge Demon weight
I yeah I'm I'm so glad to have met him
though he was just such a good guy but I
had a good time and I I murdered a lot
of animals that I ate or that will be
eaten and I drank I drank all the wine
nice wine all the wine your face doesn't
look fat no no was it was very good wine
so you oh so it doesn't hold the yeah
it's well when you drink wine that's 30
years old I had
a a whiskey I thought about you I had a
whiskey from 1891 God damn was it
haunted it was haunted and it was so
[__] good it was from 1891 was it
Henry the Eight's piss well my friend
also got himself uh a whiskey it was a
Sherry or a port uh they found at the
bottom of the sea and in a in a sunken
ship from the
1500s that can't taste good and uh and
it had been preserved underwater and
then it was in a seller for 30 years and
they opened it and it tasted fantastic
really yes cuz I cuz my boy remember
they found wine in Pompei I know go back
to when was Pompei when was Pompei black
they found wine 94 when was pompe what
pompe pomp p o m p e i when was it what
p o was PP I when when it was is that 97
nope it was
97c yeah what year was pompe destroyed
um 79 no no no no no uh yeah that's
right no no but the the original one
that's when that's when interupted
destroying oh it destroyed the ancient
we're talking even longer 79 ad so
that'd be 79 years after Jesus was born
they found wine that had been preserved
because of the ash it was it was
drinkable they're lying to you and honey
they found wine the honey I know honey
never goes and they found a Twinkie
which is crazy a twinky Twinkies don't
go bad neither does McDonald
cheeseburgers they they don't mold which
can't be healthy cannot be healthy that
can't those people are lying to you I
had cuz my boy whiskey P brought me a
whiskey from the Civil
War can't drink that it tastes like
[__] Colonel Mustard pissed down my
throat it was the worst thing that's
ever touched these legs well it probably
wasn't if it's if it's kept well cuz
remember this sh was kept at the bottom
of the sea for did you try it though I
didn't I'm telling you everyone I'm
telling you it's it's a 189 that whiskey
from
1891 and my buddy Joe doesn't drink
whiskey but it was given to him as a
gift and he said let's open it and we
had that and I got to tell you I got to
tell you it was smooth it was so smooth
and so caramelly and so good I couldn't
believe it what year was this
1891 all right I don't like what you're
doing after slave don't like
yeah slavery there's still slavery going
on in the world but yeah but you know
what I'm talking about 1865 was when
yeah so that's right after slavery some
that whiskey I got some I got
my suspicions about hold on this was
this was from France I know this was not
from the United States no I know I know
now remember you can get wine from that
because when you have certain Chate they
keep their wit wine
from right around the free slavery no no
no that was 1865 this 1891 right around
the same park no but I don't know why
why are you saying that I don't
know
just F ding down just fishing I'm sorry
why the white in France have to do with
abing slavery well you know though
there's a lot of fraud in wine you like
the Coke brothers that he bought that
wine from Thomas Jefferson it was that
Thomas Jefferson's uh seller and turned
out no it wasn't chines guy Jack Daniels
you know you know who created Jack
Daniels black
guy did you know that I didn't know the
more you know Reading Rainbow [__] I
don't think I think Jack D was
started the original ree is a black guy
founder Jack was Jasper Newton no he was
the founder the guy who created that
Jack Daniels whiskey is a black man
huh Jack he taught Jack Daniels how to
make it he was making it before then was
like Hey white boy come here then Jack
Dan's like I'm gonna make a business out
of this
oh yeah well got the old look at that
Jack Dan's recipe created by former
slave now it could have been a white
slave I don't know could have
been interesting though right
interesting right there he
looks that's him with a mustache better
than mine what a Time interesting right
you know what I got from this weekend
money buys happiness guys and that's
what I have to say you know what I mean
did you come back home you're like G no
I I missed the [__] out of my kids
I can I can do I can do four days and
then I I I panic I can't even do four
yeah I panic yeah it's tough dude it's
the flying too you know it's tough tough
did you and Tim fly back together no Tim
had somewhere else to be America [__]
yeah yeah somewhere else to be I don't
know Tim's like well it's been fun boys
and when you're leaving like enjoy your
freedom see you guys later yeah yeah
he's just doing the Lord's the way he
the way he gave me some tips on how to
what to carry with you first we're we're
on the plane also I mean we're on the
plane and he tied a tourniquet around me
for he's so hilarious he just [__] with
you sometimes like just just tied a
tourni around me I like ah ah it's
pinching he goes I'm just shutting off
here I got to do it he does whatever he
wants and just [__] then he goes
checks my pulse he goes no pulse good
you're good did you talk to him about
what's going on with like the hamus and
uh oh yeah I got cuz he knows the down
low I got when you talk to it'll hurt
your feelings like he he told me about
the the border so I was like can't be
that bad he it lit it ruined when you
talk the most horrific and he's front
line and I was like oh I don't want to
talk to you anymore about when you talk
to Tim he's had a career for the past
what 25 years at the tip of the spear
and when you talk to Tim about foreign
policy and about the reality versus what
you see on the news uh it's an education
it it's a true education and and he's
just such a good [__] dude I love him
me too I don't know who I'm more
attracted to I don't know if a bigger
man crush on Tim or Jimmy Johnson so I
was torn I was torn as a as a semi- gay
man I was torn and uh I'd probably go
with Jimmy if I had to like you talking
about you to be a Psy I'd go with Jimmy
cuz he's retired he's worth all the
money in the world yeah but Tim and I
would be fighting over Jimmy and I think
I'd lose that one Tim travels too much
so you're at home alone not getting that
dick yeah yeah yeah yeah uh his son is
also a crazy athlete his son is uh I
think eight years old and and uh how
could he not be and and yeah his his
whole family his dad was Olympian his
dad I think was a Olympic Polo player
yeah he's such a so he comes from yeah
he comes from crazy gentics such a good
person he apparently is the smaller one
in his family I know every brother's 6'4
yeah everyone's big yeah his dad's 6'4
big men big boys yeah and uh yeah so
glad you had fun buddy welcome back to
America thank you it's good to be back
you i'mna watch I I doubt it you were
gone the DeSantis and Nome debate I
didn't I watched the highlights I watch
I rushed home from my son's baseball
practice give me your give me your take
I rushed home and watched it like you I
said this on my tweet like it was step B
versus Jon Jones yes I would I couldn't
wait the problem with Des Sant is he
just doesn't have that it Factor like if
that was a trump or a guy who's like you
know charismatic and can really go at
somebody they would have lit new him up
but the S is so like calculated and you
know well thought you know so he didn't
he he he destroyed him but it was in
like this more formal way you know yeah
he made new some look really bad cuz
like you're just lying this all you do
you lie to the people you lie to me this
is what you're notoriously known for so
and he did bring him up on a lot of like
lies who who was were you surprised by
nome's uh comebacks was he no I called
it because my because my father-in-law
was like oh get ready new about get
destroyed now I go that's the mistake
you're making he's a career politician
he's very smart and there's a reason why
he signed up for this debate coming into
Hannity coming into the lions den he I I
was like get ready Steve because this
dude one thing can do that [__]
can debate so you know but again Dan
santis doesn't have the most you know
energy so to santis for sure won but in
the grand scheme of things it didn't
help him with like he's not going to be
Trump doesn't matter it didn't it didn't
he won he did he like I I bet his party
goes yeah you did your job but no one's
like dude you blew the roof off this I
only set the part with the parental
rights and the uh the Poop Map of s San
Francisco did he have any rebuttal to
those things not really he called him
homophobic basically yeah he kept doing
that and then the biggest one was oh Des
santis who's a good one he goes he goes
you know uh Gavin he goes I was uh in
Florida uh obviously during the during
the lockdowns and I had this old man
come up to me and he goes I moved from
California I can't thank you enough I
feel free here this is America I can't
thank you enough and Des s goes of
course that's what we do here and he
goes you know who that was gab goes who
he goes it was your stepdad yeah that
was great I was I went roast roast and
then after that it was kind of downhill
from there but it's just you know the
politicians just two [__] artists
it's no different than WWE but the Santa
at least might as been stone cold in the
rock up there yeah but Santa is a little
different he was in the Navy captain of
his baseball team in college still a
politician though you know like he says
one thing an effective one for sure yeah
yeah for sure I mean I'm I'm biased of
course yeah oh me too I love to S but he
just doesn't have that factor he don't
have that JFK that Obama you know even
the Trump he just doesn't have that that
people are going to be go for him you
know it's a bummer because he can do it
but it is it
is well but that's it dude did you see
Mike Perry no Eddie beer knuckle no I
didn't know that was this weekend I was
in I was in
Europe yeah those guys aren't in the
fisted cuffs but Eddie Alvarez uh his
team threw in the toal the second round
his eye was completely shut oh Jesus
yeah Mike's I'm telling you Mike is too
big Fredy Mike's way bigger he was way
bigger but Luke rockold is bigger than
than Mike and he destroyed destroyed
Luke he beat up Luke where thing did EDD
Eddie was there is a fight EDD I thought
Eddie won the first round me too like
Eddie was G him a [__] fight knuckle
bro maybe broke his eye orbital but he
couldn't see the Mark Henry who's you
know my boy his coach Eddie was still
down to go but he was like no more you
can't see out your eye he's like we're
not doing this this is be knuckle yeah
you stop why why do that to yourself I
mean it's crazy what what with no gloves
do to you right yeah now do you uh were
they were they so what is what is Mike
Perry's ability is he is he just keeps
his head down he's just he's just
tougher than everybody he's just good at
it and good yeah good at it good at it
he's found he caught out Anthony Pettis
next Anthony again too small small yeah
yeah well he put out a tweet that today
calling out a Jorge mazol that'd be
interesting that would be a crazy murder
worlds that's a good fight yeah but but
um that's a good fight if I'm I'm not
doing
that I don't know man or's a bad he's
done it you know like you get to a point
where it feels like Mike has got still
got that enthusiasm he loves it how old
is Mike Perry 38 no that old old oh okay
he's a lot younger no there you
go age is a big fact 32 he's so young
but Jorge fought on the street so I
think that would be actually a really
good fight yeah cuz Jorge knows how to
fight with be Knuckles and and and and
Jorge has his own that's the only
problem there is Jorge has his own MMA
so they'd have to maybe you know cross
promote but they could figure it out
it'd be good for both of them if they
did cross promote do a couple bare
knuckle MMA and then a couple boxing on
the same card make a stat card that'd be
sick that would be beautiful that would
be dope yeah the two you know like the
most famous people from both
organizations yeah that'd be dope does
he does did they are they still Ginger
with their hands no be knck so no not
this not these guys they were Mike
Perry's not yeah wow Eddie Ed the
Eddie's 39
damn 39 I me Mike Perry is actually in
his prime at 32 that's super young and
he just found his Niche he was he's
killing it dude he's killing it do like
he was a good UFC fighter not like a
world beater this world beater yeah who
else wants he doesn't seem take damage
he keeps his head down what is it takes
damage but they're hitting he's catching
shots he takes a lot of damage yeah
bring up the his I let me get this big
he no he's just tougher he just has a
better chin he's also younger yes so age
is a huge factor in this
game what who else would you say uh who
else fought anybody else I would know oh
who won between Rothwell and Duffy no no
that that got canceled because uh I
think uh Rothwell pulled out because of
a flu or something like that which just
lame and Duffy talks smack about that
like what the hell dude is it Sean Duffy
Todd Duffy remember um stud yeah I
haven't seen him or heard from him in a
minute this going to be his debut on
beard
knuckle he's a freak man he's a you were
you trained him right oh yeah a long
time he's my
boy yeah I met him when I was at AKA and
he's just a CH guy what do you bring oh
you bringing up his face yeah well I had
it earlier with the bookmarks but it's
not popping
up yeah you get caught you just type in
Mike Perry's I did I did it didn't pop
up how big Ian it was worse we had on
shop show you saw he had like a huge
lump on the side of his face I mean yeah
you don't do bare knuckle and get out
unscathed yeah how big is this sport
now what' you say I don't know bud
compared to what I mean pay-per-view
numbers I don't know I don't know are
you being Koi No I prom I I don't know I
don't know like compared to Major UFC py
yeah it's not close but they're they're
new and then mazad doll what his team
does is really smart is you know it's
tough enough with the content out there
then when you're asking to put it behind
a pay wall so what they do is they put
it out for free on YouTube live to get
the fan base so they're getting millions
of views cuz people like I'll watch a
free fight sure so instead of putting
behind a pay wall it's brilliant until
you get to a certain point where you
have stars they you can start charging
but it's it's
great yeah I I don't know pay-per-view
model's tough dude tough
tough
wow what else you got J you see the uh
what else we got you see the there's a
comedy club uh oh Sam sent in DC yeah
Capital comedy report on the comics if
they make you feel if they H anybody
says anything about somebody ethnic
Origins sexual orientation and it's so
hilarious like all the things you legit
post they're like make sure you tell us
which comic made you
feel so he don't they and Comics should
tell other Comics these are the most
tyrannical people find out the owners of
these [__] it's hilarious so Sam post
it on his Instagram or where yeah Sam
post on Instagram you don't have to but
again who would play there I mean you
know what legit com AR who aren't funny
yeah that's right what legit Comics
going to play at that club is is
harassment Capital laughs like what what
is that Capital laughs Treasures our
community's humor and the comedians we
book offer their time and talents and to
make people laugh we have to support
each other so in that Spirit we insist
we insist folks we book treat our
community members with respect refrain
from race-based sex-based sexual
orientation based gender identity based
national origin based religious based or
any other based harass it is wrong it
will not be tolerated and it is so
unnecessary when we have a town full of
politicians we can disrespect on
stage I just don't know seriously though
you should know that we will not
tolerate these behaviors and we will not
book comedians who we determine either
engage in them encourage them or fail to
let us know when others do we are not
your parent or your boss but we are
telling you how we feel and what we will
do did something happen at a show that
made you feel uncomfortable let Elena or
Jack know Place Elena or Jack you are
tyrants you are anti-comedy and uh you
should um you should take a pick up a
history book and see how well that works
also you don't know anything about
comedy you're
uh suicide for that CL they're also
they're also just they suck you suck
they're also probably headed out of
business like we need to do something
well they're they're the kind of people
also that are um so I think that place
has like uh uh troops that sing
satirical comedy stuff about you know
politics DC's a great great City have
you ever seen though like the the like
the
NPR uh sort of intellect intelligencia
they laugh at the corniest [__] they're
not funny people they're just like well
I mean at that point I think I ate
enough mashed potatoes where people were
looking at me crosy uh and and my my
sister was like you might want to leave
some for uh you know the rest of the
guests and we had such a laugh are you
going to have some match potatoes with
that gravy right literally yeah yeah I
mean at one point my my my uh I had a
mountain of mashed potatoes and my my
sister used the word Mountain so so
that's so much carrots they thought it
was a
rabbit yeah that's right that's right
that's right so uh yes literally what do
you call black
astronaut an astronaut you racist you
[__]
racist I don't know if they're doing
that joke there no no they they would
they would even they don't they're so
non-racist they don't even see color
they're
incredible they're incredible they're
just [__]
hilarious yeah Club it's career Su DC's
when I went back to DC oh I told you I
had an issue there yeah I told oh yeah
they can go [__] themselves how about
that I had a big issue there yeah DC is
where Innovation goes to die DC is like
uh this conservative sty place it's like
you it's a cool City you he the
as you ever hear you ever hear the
expression uh politician I can't
remember who said it he was a career
politician he said Washington he goes if
you want a friend in Washington buy a
dog so true it's [__] people and then
Hillary Clinton said or get a kid Henry
ker just died at 100 years old one of
the great Statesmen and reviled and
admired great run hundo great great run
and a real player was uh I believe uh
Richard Nixon's uh secretary of State um
or was it Secretary of Defense look that
up uh uh Henry Kissinger Henry Kissinger
was the guy who broker the deal that
that brought China and America back
together blah blah blah broke up the
sinos Soviet thing I mean amazing yeah
Secretary of State yes and U A wise wise
man and he said he watched when he
watched The Godfather he said to Robert
Evans just like Washington just
different names and they kill you
differently not with a gun but rep
reputationally he true
yeah he's not American though no no he
was from Germany he was Jewish and he
was a he looks like he's melting yeah
he's 100 years old and he was Jewish and
he lost a lot of his family in the
Holocaust so he looked at the world very
different oh I bet y he called it real
politique man like there's there's a way
to do
things had had a very very uh had a very
thick accent you know and his his
brother spoke fluent English no accent
and he said why does why does your
brother have such a thick accent and he
said because my brother does most of the
talking less
listening yeah but he was he when he
spoke everybody
listened Henry Kissinger 100 years old
okay so chin I was going to ask what you
got but I I'll tell you what I want I'll
tell you what I want you and brow have
been creating some magic in the kitchen
I want to see you AIC can you can you
insert this into the episode the fans
can share sure thanks BR yeah bash this
is this your so no but I'm not going to
we're cuz we didn't put this video out
yet but so but I'll play for you guys
right now so this is uh but why not put
in this to Hype it up the whole thing
though yeah how long is it it's it's a
whole song though we three minutes our
song's coming out on Tuesday which is
when this episode comes out so put it in
there put it in let me let me think
about it okay anyways I'll just play for
you guys uh it's called we don't
close I'll tell you about it after this
and I wrote this song We Don't Close I
wrote this song for
you and the guy that directed this is
me
whiskey that's from all our like
shows you can put it on my tab again
sorry I'm babbling I'm just thinking is
this a waste of my time oh just wasting
the night again only one thing on my
mind only one thing on my mind again if
you leave leaving and you leaving me
right back here alone baby we will know
that I could go to batt on my own CU
we
know we won't let this
go
drink
slow CU we don't C and you said I
Amin baby that's my favorite part walk
out oh and I know you don't need me need
me baby and that just makes me want you
even
[Music]
more Ryan so Stone
Face taking it in
great I love it man so good thanks dude
great song great song so it's a great
song CH so yes it's called sound amazing
I think that the video I think the video
should be um uh I feel almost like you
you could tell the story through imagery
too of what the song is saying right so
it's called we don't close it's like
it's it's like you know you hanging out
with a girl and you go out afterwards
you know we don't stop hanging out and
stuff but stop can't stop won stop you
know what I'm saying the main meaning of
it is like we don't stop working we're
always working we're always constantly
working on the main message is you ain't
going the main message is the main
message you ain't leaving main messages
we're main messages I locked the door
you ain't leaving we're Le leaving
lock main mess messes we going [__] yeah
main message is it don't care how long
it take we [__] we [__] we work hard we
[__] hard [__] [__] by that I mean we
[__] other yep suck hard uh so that that
is one of the best gay videos I've ever
seen in my life yeah it's actually a
really good song Oh the song so catchy
yeah really cuz I got a little snip of
it the leave that's my favorite your
voice is great man his appreciate it uh
you he's such a good guy brow best he's
such a good man and thanks for you know
letting me put this in theth you're
great no it's at least I can do is write
it and produce it what I didn't know you
wrote that those lyrics are deep and
down and uh fresh they're fresh
fresh that's what we do here man we make
fresh
cool scumbag I know this is just from
the post but U have you guys seen this
interview with uh Chris Wallace No let
me see and Adam Driver okay so he's
asking like cuz you know Adam Driver has
a you know a different kind of look so
anyway I'll just play the he's so
talented yes he is am I thinking of the
right guy let me
see hold on we have to go through ads
has that don't look like the typical
movie star has that been he you don't
look like a typical movie star you look
sweet well i' I've worked consistently
which is nice with people that I've
wanted to always dreamed that I wanted
to work with and I so in that sense it
hasn't uh I look how I look I can't I
can't change that so I guess it it it
helped
me um yeah I don't know a hindrance and
and only uh breaking mirrors wherever I
go and uh and having a you know misshape
and outsized body that I can't fit
through doorways or most clothes or uh
fit into most cars that made me sad yeah
so he's like you think look let me
tell about ad driver uh he's got no
problems getting all the girls of course
I know but it's not even about that but
imagine that like man I can't believe
you made it despite your looks I'd be
like hold up hold up what hold on you
tell me what's wrong with my looks you
look like [__] bro and you're the one
that I got paid for this interview you
[__] idiot well I I do think that
Adam Driver was talked about from the
beginning of his career as a guy who
didn't look like a typical movie star he
didn't have the symmetry so that that
was a thing actually I he's not an ugly
human being no he's also he's also giant
guy big he was a marine stupid talented
but but he's all man dude he's better
looking than anybody in here are you
[__] me well I'm a good-looking guy
but yeah I know look at him look at him
next to the you would have look at him
like I can't believe this guy made him
6'4 he's a big boy too dude that's a
good-looking [__] dude yeah yeah yeah
dude there are lots of most all the
girls he steals everybody's girl here
Talent level yeah he seals all the girls
he's he's as tall as a horse the horse
you know what he says he goes I need a
bigger horse you know what I've never
had to say I need a bigger horse now you
ride ponies he says I need a bigger
horse you know what else he says you
watch this you know what else he says
that I've never said I can't do that
movie I'm too busy yeah how big how big
is he he's 6 four three four 4755 think
everybody's monster cuz you're small
he's 7
foot so he's shorter than um I think
he's taller than that of course you do
yeah but it's just [__] up oh Bor he's
only 6'2 it's not that big they always
talk about how big he is he seems tall
though well for for actors for actors
are tiny and gay I guess he's big his
body's big he's not though he's the
average size but in Hollywood all you
guys are small and gay so it's like you
figure it out like alberino is 5'4 like
damn take a look at but with Adam Driver
dude it's not like he's some atrocious
looking human being where the start the
like I can't dude look at you man you've
done it desp what Chris Wallace was
doing was that Adam Driver was talked
about for a long time as being the
unlikely looking movie star that's
stupid I saw all day cuz he was um
quieter he wasn't overly Charisma
talented though yeah so good yeah I saw
him on stage saw him in a in uh burn
this on got a time show together man
yeah you shouldn't marry him um what
else you got Jin uh this is just a fun
one I think this is obviously just like
a just for attention but anyway so
apparently a lot of people responding to
this thing where a guy is looking at
this girl and they're they're saying
that he's actually doing the respectful
Thing by just looking at her and moving
on so I'll just show this video real
quick God jesz you see the guy in the
background
smoking he's just taking in like a fine
painting so I I guess a bunch of the
comments were about like gorgeous she's
insane yeah she's insane I have her
Instagram here too she's very pretty but
I mean people are saying like this is
how you're supposed to do it like just
look en enjoy and then he's creepy there
he's
like he's super creepy
there this obviously probably like part
of her plan I don't know what the I mean
I mean I guess we give this guy Kudos I
mean he didn't go hey mama is that her
is that her that's her yeah she's she's
I mean she's insane yeah obviously
insane it's ridiculous first of all she
does this she's she's a she's
a look at her ass she's an angel yeah
that's Ang ah the bikini no that one's
cool the one on the motorcycle I mean no
I mean hey can you punch me in my
[__] face right now can you rip my
dick off cuz Rock Christ man hey can you
put my dick in a [__] I'm going to
suck atar in your mouth hey can you
armar my dick in your mouth cuz I'm
brocc yeah I'm going to do that look at
her there oh her waight in her ass J get
it out of here get your get your dick
out let me just put it in yeah I got to
take care of you yeah um but so yeah
well I mean she's a she's a free it's
funny cuz people are giving her props
about like or giving the guy props for
just like looking and moving up look at
us anybody who doesn't look at her Is
Not a Human Being it's that when when
they look like that and they go by if
you're an alien women look at her too
everyone looks at her oh but it's it's
like it's like a car like a [__] F40
goes by I got to look bury your face in
my crotch huh
what all right so this is AA like a
scene out of the fireing the kid Asian
one we did it really does how great was
that this is a a restaurant in Japan uh
people are just lining up to do this
thing where they get slapped in the face
before they enter and it's like pretty
hard slaps dude that's a woman too she
get her
CTE
oh
I don't but why do this the the
customers are actually paying to I know
but do they have like the best dumplings
in New York or something I think this
must be a sexual fetish it has to be
right see if you can take it I'll take a
back the girls take it not dude I'll
take some dim sum and a dick suck if you
slap me but I'm not just going to do it
for your low man bro everybody gets
slapped it's like take the slap dude
yeah I know Antonio and Noki The Old Pro
wrestler that fought uh Muhammad Ali he
used to smack people like every time he
met him it oh yeah see smacks [__] at
him yeah but I don't I don't get why you
would do this though it's just like I
said it's a gimmick it's a gimmick for
the restaurant but people want to line
up and pay it but it's like $2 us is it
called cuck R Us it must be something
sexual I think but then there's girls
getting slapped too it's called cuck
Express there are people that love
having their balls kicked in too I mean
there's lots of that stuff God I don't
get that most stuff I can look I'm like
all right guess I can see how you can
get there that one I'm like in what
world I knew I knew a woman who's a
Dominatrix and uh she used to had she
had an office where you come in uh most
of her clients were lawyers I probably
told you this before but she would they
had a she had a chair a metal chair
where you would sit and your balls and
Co could go through the metal chair and
then she would tie your balls to a she
put a a ring around your the base of
your and then tie it to the floor and
now you can't go anywhere okay and then
you and do all kind sick though like
don't they get sick I mean you and I
would I'm not into that but a lot of how
do they not get sick like the rest of
the world because but also do they nut
when you go in there like they K some
people are into being treated like aate
from from the tension yeah all that
stuff ohd all right now see now now you
got they whip him they get whipped peed
on all that stuff yeah I'm just that's
just not my thing not my thing not my
thing but also like let's say you were a
guy like this nuts kicked like do you
want to go to the store here come here
no got to be a lady no I'll do it but
hey before we go to air one no no no
it's got to be a hot lady with a high
heel you remember crumb crumb he was a
he was a cartoonist yeah I remember that
guy he was into uh bring up crum's
cartoons he was into big strong girls
carrying him on their back and just he
was a weird guy he looks like he lik be
on your back such an interesting pervert
he looks like he wants to jump on your
back like a real pervert want to be a
backpack like that stuff right yeah it
was all that weird stuff with really big
legs he was such a he's probably a small
guy I think his I think his brother was
uh arrested for all kinds of creepy
stuff feel like you and him like the
same kind of chick well yeah but right I
mean yeah he liked those big strong look
at that well that's just him with
Bigfoot with he was just he was just it
was all kinds of weird um
yeah I mean lik something thick dud this
I think yeah arcrum
Comics there's there's a really
interesting documentary on it how many
how many Comics you have I don't have
any I I never I've never heard of it I
was never a Comic Book Guy were you big
time you were who was your comic book I
liked
um Lobo I love Lobo carnage venom like
the Joker ones but Lobo is my main thing
I the little Batman little werewolf
little
Hulk us name now famous
superheroes what else you got J um so we
have this Georg you will talk about it
but we'll see if we can put on the oh
yeah I saw this reposted from Black
Rifle coffee this is a crazy Bear bow
hunting situation right
here oh that's such a bad
thing so bad that's not a good
idea holy
CRA who's
filming oh the beer was going away I
know
yeah but the beer was
leaving
yeah this is Brian in uh Europe I don't
like seeing
this I don't like it either that's why I
was like saying like I'm not
[Music]
sure oh that's our boy too that's a long
bow is that is that it is interesting
though but him no no what um yes so I'm
not sure if we're going to put this in
but it was interesting well hunting bear
but but the fact that the bear kind of
like sniffed and then went away that's
what I I don't if the bear was like like
yeah kill the idea the bear was like the
bear let you live the bear could have
killed you and then I guess the idea was
the bear was walking away and there's
that sort of
idea walk out of good faith I I I
wouldn't want to kill a bear personally
but would you care that be that bear or
one of those cute ass deers yeah well
deer I eat you can eat bear too but I
bear I I've always been uneasy about
bear killing a bear yeah it but also is
it hunting when the bear saw you and is
walking away it's kind of like talking
[__] and then the guy's like all right
it's over man you shoot him in the back
of the head yeah is that really G I
guess he was there hunting right for
that's like that's that's a tough
argument I know and you know you may not
see a bear again so but I don't know I
got he's got balls for shooting that
thing staying in there it's not even a
compound bow that's a long recurve bow
yeah it was so close and so so a
compound bow would go a lot of times
really deep in that bear I think a lot
deeper than that well you know the first
B we leave this in what's up do we leave
this part in I don't know man I don't I
probably think we we we don't show it we
maybe talk about it that's it yeah we'll
just like say we're oh really okay I was
just more worried about if it's
entertain yeah for me like to me it's
super interesting it's interesting yeah
it's something to talk about for sure
but it's that's it's [__] if I'm going
to kill a deer I'm going to eat every
piece of it I love the meat so same
thing with an Al same thing any of that
stuff so no problem I'm also going to
take a shot where I know I'm going to
kill it right away I don't take shots a
long way cuz I can't this is this is
disrespectful is this from son this is
from s so it speaks for itself I'll just
play the
[Music]
video so little kid flipping off the
other team yeah yeah but see I don't
think it's a I don't approve of that Nei
yeah I would never let my never let my
kid my kid Dad did do that to if he does
it at that age like imagine when he
grows up like what the hell man bad bad
[__] um I think this might be sosis too
but I'm not sure but yeah so anyways uh
it says the Jets designated quarterback
I don't know where snaz got this this is
four days ago the Jets came out and said
he's not coming back okay she did sure
she sent it a while ago so might have
pretty sure yeah I don't think it's
happening I don't understand oh yeah
speaking of fights during football games
uh cornerback Kyler Gordon got his
helmet broke after getting punched
repeated repeatedly in the Vikings game
and he still got the
flags with the interception to Midfield
to the 45
r
hey yeah let's
go his helmet's all broke
unsportsmanlike conduct by Chicago
number six for taking his he still got
he got flaged for taking his helmet
broke after he someone punched him in
the helmet which just that's funny
messed up
yeah well the face mask is broken the
end of the Shelf we keep showing
football one more one more thing is it
better than that or jelly will our boy
yeah push Rey Mysterio's
son [__] you
Dominic yeah Jelly's just freaking
killing it right now dude everywhere
yeah he's mainstream now I love it love
that dude no way better yeah the
sweetest well I also love Chicago I will
be there this Friday Saturday jez Friday
Saturday Chicago two shows Friday two
shows Saturday wow that was quick I'm
missing my kids freaking Little League
game so make sure you come Friday and
Saturday TI at thick boy.com then
Nashville one night only January 25th
then Austin the 26 27th get your ticket
at thick
boy.com uh guys great news uh I will be
in Indianapolis this Thursday Friday
Saturday December 7 89 at Helium Comedy
Club I then go to spaan Washington
December 15 16 I got off the hook in
Naples Florida December 21 22 23 and
then the comedy zone 28 29 3031 uh and
uh check out my new podcast off limits
off liit episode available now new
episode every Thursday for everybody
every Thursday I drop them check it out
all right kids that's it love you